comment allez-vous j'espère que ça va
bien écoutez aujourd'hui on va parler
des live vous suivez un peu de Live vous
passez vraiment en train de rentrer fort
dans la culture la joie mon père m'en a
parlé c'est marrant j'ai vraiment ça en
référence quand mes parents ils me
parlent d'un truc je me dis waouh ça y
est c'est un franchi la limite du grand
public tout le monde connaît maintenant
tout le monde est au courant même mes
parents qui sont pas du tout de cette
génération là c'est incroyable mon père
le jour il va me parler de la crypto
monnaie je vais m'évanouir on a fini à
très longtemps regardez un peu des fails
qui a eu en plein live aujourd'hui c'est
ça mais il y a pas que des fêtes c'est
juste des trucs mignons amusant ou cool
qui sont passés en live parce que le
format du live ce qui est drôle c'est
qu'il y a énormément d'imprévus et
surtout ces imprévus tu peux pas les les
cacher puisque ça s'est passé en live
voilà comme moi à Tokyo là 3h du mat
quand j'étais bourré que j'ai acheté un
kebab tu assumes dis Louis it et c'est
tout j'adore exemple ici on a un
streamer qui fait un cache-cache à IKEA
déjà ça me fait céder il y a des
entreprises qui vendent des meubles et
qui ont pas anticipé le flow number one
de leur magasin les gens qui font des
cache-cache
c'est terrible ils vont se retrouver à
devoir mettre des pics dans les
dressings et tout pour pas que les gens
puissent s'y cacher c'est triste
les gars je suis content d'avoir vu
cette vidéo parce que on était des
millions ici à ne pas suspecter que des
gens puissent être cachés dans des
dressing quand on ouvre la porte les
gars allez faire des cache-cache
c'est vrai que c'est drôle je vais
lancer un truc Ikea je suis pas
responsable disque gamer voilà les
mentions légales de ma vidéo Ikea je ne
suis pas responsable si les gens
s'amusent dans vos magasins à faire des
cache-cache ne m'attaquez pas en justice
sponsorisez-moi plutôt ok ça les gars ça
les gars ça me rend ouf lui c'est Tyler
one c'est un streamer spécialisé dans la
musculation pas du tout il joue à League
of Legend c'est bon alors pourquoi
a-t-il ce corps il a la particularité
d'être extrêmement stock à tel point que
il te fait des soulevés de terre mon
frérot c'est des soulever de planètes
qui te fait d'accord déjà sont soulevés
tel est tellement ouf que il y a des
commentateurs je savais même pas qu'il y
avait des commentateurs de soulever de
terre c'est incroyable tu veux dire quoi
à part la barre a quitté le sol bien
joué la barre est de retour au sol bravo
[Musique]
tellement une autre culture après je
vais vous dire le secret il joue à LoL
vous rendez compte le niveau de haine et
de frustration qu'il faut avoir pour
être capable d'un coup de se lâcher de
soulever en tel point il y a que les
joueurs de LoL quand sont capables
sachez tout de même pour ceux qui
n'avaient pas vu que on a fait avec le
client une séance de sport en live on
n'avait pas trop communiqué dessus parce
que vous voulez pas faire complexer tout
le Game des streamers youtubeur et tout
mais laissez-moi vous dire que cette
séance elle était waouh oh
non c'est trop mignon c'est un jeune qui
a laissé tourner son stream et sa mère
elle est venue s'adresser au viewer du
jeune
frère super streaming
oh c'est trop mignon non mais là
vraiment vous rendez compte j'aimerais
pas que ça m'arrive je peux dire que le
jour où je suis aux toilettes avec ma
mère vient s'asseoir ici pour vous dire
merci vraiment pour Lucas il est très
heureux le dossier ah je vais angoisser
toute la journée on y repensant oh merde
mais lui dans son cas c'est adorable je
trouve
my Sunshine mayonnais Sunshine ça
devient un peu
tu peux arrêter c'était mignon au début
là c'est dommage
arrêtez vous voulez juste gratter des
abonnés les gars arrêtez ça se voit je
veux dire il a deux doigts avec son
arobase dessus qui veux-tu berner jeune
enfant les gars d'ailleurs sur les lavis
réels il y a des bas imaginez quand il y
aura la 5G et tout tout le monde va live
IRL très souvent ça veut dire quand tu
sortiras dans la rue il y a de grandes
chances pour qu'un moment donné tu te
retrouves en live sur internet sur la
chaîne de quelqu'un à ton insu c'est un
peu ma dent je trouve suis-je un boomer
oh ça c'est ma passion c'est les petits
streamers qui se font daronnade ils sont
en live ils font du bruit ou je sais pas
quoi et il y a quelqu'un qui ouvre la
porte et qu'il est rose
[Musique]
mais qu'est-ce qu'il fait ce streamer
fais des pompes
mais il se passe quoi là il se change
[Musique]
en plus je trouve que tu as l'air
vachement idiot quand tu fais ça
reproviseur m'a appelé pour me dire
qu'il ne croyait pas du tout en toi et
en tout potentiel tu es misérable
franchement lui il a géré son daronnage
il reste un passible il râle pas il
admet ses tort il essaie d'être
expéditif mais elle est surenchée encore
et encore à tel point qu'à un moment il
est obligé de lâcher le morceau il lui
dire
il y a un truc impitoyable avec les live
c'est que c'est très dur quand tu
commences à live et d'attirer des gens
sur tes live le phénomène du monde qui
attire le monde sur les lives il est
décuplé et là c'est un streamer qui
parle de mathématiques et méga passionné
et tout et c'est la première fois en des
dizaines d'heures de Live qu'il a un
viewer son premier viewer
[Musique]
bref c'est trop mignon je j'étais à 15
secondes de la fin j'assume pas
[Musique]
c'est quoi ce live aussi là il fait une
dégustation de tout ce qu'il y a à la
caisse à Carrefour ou c'est comment là
je ne comprends pas comment il se
déboîtent les volets excusez-moi
c'est pour ça que je danse pas les gars
c'est pas que je sais pas danser tu
imagines le truc juste c'est dangereux
mec oh ça ça les gars peut-être je vais
baisser dans votre estime ou peut-être
c'est vous qui allez monter dans mon
estime si ça vous fait marrer bordel
[Musique]
oh c'est tellement drôle les gars c'est
tellement la blague que tu fais quand tu
assumes pas trop un peu mais tu le fais
en blague lui tu es la du premier de
ce que c'est frérot tu as de l'air chaud
sous les fesses au moment où on se parle
fais-nous un petit top 1 et c'est bon
c'est derrière nous ok ça oh le combo
vous avez chialer c'est une streameuse
qui a plus de 65 ans aux US et ça fait
des années qu'elle joue à Minecraft et
qu'elle fait un monde regardez
[Musique]
quand elle est trop fière oh là là ça va
sous terre et tout non mais rendez-vous
il est incroyable ce monde vous pensez
que notre génération sera ce genre de 69
est-ce que la Fast Forward hop 40 ans
plus tard vous ouvrez YouTube et twitch
et on est toujours là à faire des vidéos
des lives on a juste des rides on est
tous contents mais on se fait nos petits
kiffes on continue à live et entre nous
tu as trop hâte de voir ça ah ça ça tue
Charles Leclerc pilote de F1 il est en
plein live twitch et là il y a un subs
donc il remercie le sub et le sub
s'appelle Charlotte Ciney Charlotte
Ciney c'est la copine de Charles Leclerc
du coup lui naturellement
relou c'est moyen comme blague ah
[Rires]
trop malin si vous n'arrivez pas à
joindre un ami à vous qui est streamer
laisser un message en vous abonnant à
son twitch c'est 100 % écurique suis-je
en train de dire ça pour voler 5 € à
tous mes amis et évidemment c'est pas
juste et settings Obs qui peuvent ruiner
ton live ou bien c'est logiciels qu'on
utilise pour streamer
[Musique]
un mec en même temps mec si je puis me
permettre tu l'as bien rentabilisé ton
étagère il y a plus un millimètre carré
de dispo là je vais dire une phrase
juste pour faire kiffer les bricoleur il
avait mis des chevilles ou pas dans son
mur les gars j'ai découvert l'existence
de la cheville et il est vrai c'est game
et c'est ce qui fait que ce miroir qui
vous angoisse tant depuis qu'on a fait
le nouveau bureau avec Lorraine n'est
toujours pas tombé la cheville
activité manuelle on en a fait on a fait
un gameplay en live je l'ai pas fini
mais tout s'est bien passé lui c'est
quoi c'est comme si c'était un gros cube
en Lego ah mais c'est genre un gros
Rubik's Cube en tout cas ça a l'air très
long
adieu c'est top qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
ça va péter fort il y a une cam pour son
chien ça tue
mon cœur il s'est arrêté encore une fois
j'en ai marre dans toutes les vidéos en
ce moment il y a un truc
plus un streamer c'est endormi à son
réveil il commet le clutch non mais
attends mais on est où là mais qu'est-ce
que c'est que ça à quel moment tu es en
train de jouer ACS et tu t'endors comme
ça mais mec c'est ta chaise de bureau
ton lit là donc là il se réveille Eva
cloche c'est-à-dire il va faire gagner
le round à son équipe
[Musique]
[Rires]
comment c'est possible ça moi je
m'endors pas sur ma chaise et j'ai
jamais fait un clutch ça me saoule cette
salle secret messieurs dames c'est la
fin de cette vidéo l'avez-vous apprécié
moi oui j'adore cet air du live je
trouve ça génial moi je me mets vraiment
à regarder de plus en plus alors c'est
et en fait je me suis habitué à
l'ambiance un peu reposante qui a sur
les live il y a pas de code d'action
d'effet de montage c'est très genre
smooth naturel ça se consomme très
différemment des vidéos je consomme
toujours pas mal de vidéos mais j'avoue
que j'ai en ce moment je découvre des
trucs en live parce que il se passe trop
de choses quoi en live c'est n'importe
quoi allez prenez soin de vous à très
vite dans une dans cette vidéo plein de
bisous les couilles
[Musique]